The adrenaline is intense.
The concentration of focus,...
...trying to stay relaxed, I guess, you know, is key.
I didn't know if it was going to be terrifying...
..or if it was going to be blowing my neck out or whatever.
It's really, I think, hard to understand...
...the full impact of what that means right now.
How scared are you now of a scale of one to ten?
How are you?
How are you feeling?
Better than you!
Today, I'm here driving the 919.
I, of course, thought it was a lie.
I thought there's no chance they're going to let me drive the legend.
I can't believe that this is real.
It's just like a spaceship.
So, so pumped.
I think they're extremely nervous.
I've tried to get as much help and advice as I can there.
Go fast.
Don't screw it up.
Oh my god, yeah!
Everybody knows it's the best day of my life!
Unbelievable.
I don't want to come in.
Come on, a little bit more!
I got on the power tool going towards seven and then it squiggles.
I think I pooped a little bit.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
That was awesome!
The opportunity that the three guys had is truly exceptional...
...and they're mentioning that it's blowing them away.
It makes me kind of giddy, I can't stop smiling.
It's just exhilarating.
Can I come back?
That's the question.
It's the ultimate thing.
I guess I'm completely ruined now for all the other cars.
I want to come back and do it more.